[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you mean I can't wear it it's
not regulation was regulation I'm sorry
but you know this is game day there's
nothing else we can do except go by the
regulation what are you worried about
happening what it moves around on my
baby wrists I don't know about your
nutrition habits but also this is what
could happen what if it viewer says oh
maybe should I start the Dolphins
defense this week against the Patriots
you say Oh what you knock yourself out
concussion against the rules hard object
policy you know what time it is it's
time for your fantasy fire drill
why from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
bad
[Applause]
that's great wonderful thank you so much
I wonder it was wonderful you know it's
not wonderful you suggesting Dion Lewis
as a sleeper again
I can't quit him oh you know what I quit
listening to you don't listen to her
listen to me don't quit it is time for
your fantasy fire drill right now week
number two is upon us I am at camp and
we are here at the sports book in
Caesars in Las Vegas and you could find
us here every single Sunday morning
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific as we get you
ready with injuries and actives I'll
take a bunch of your questions sleepers
you name it and yeah I got naked wrists
I'm trying not to get fine so what are
we gonna do for you we'll get you ready
for everything as we get going right now
but we got to know about those injuries
get your questions in I'll be in the app
as soon as we're done if I didn't get to
your question I'll be taking them and as
soon as this completes now a little
campfire talk to get things going why
because we've won may have been great
for you or it may have been terrible if
you had Tyriq ill see him for a while
Darius Geist not gonna see him for a
while my guy Evan Coleman he's gonna
miss some time hunter Henry another knee
injury way too many injuries coming out
of week number one and if you survive
that and you scored the most points
congratulations you got a long way to go
maybe the injury bug will hit you this
week that is why you must stay on the
waiver wire if you continue to win you
go to four no keep hitting the waiver
wire we talked about this in the
preseason think about people who won
championships they had Elijah McGuire
they went up and picked up Damien
Williams you have to hit continue to hit
that waiver wire because somebody right
now that's not on a roster will be in a
championship roster so if you had to get
over those injuries you're hitting the
waiver wire and regardless of where you
stand in the standings make sure you
continue to manage that team now let's
get into the inactives for this week
it's not
terrible group but there are some
prominent names here so let's go over
and we will update this throughout the
show we don't have an official word on
Joe Mixon yet he is expected to play
however he is not 100% he is outside of
my top 20 running backs for this week
Mike Williams also expected to play but
not an official word yet we will update
it as soon as we have it a knee issue
that had popped up at the end of the
week
he may be in red zone packages according
to multiple reports so the little
worried there Mark Ingram officially
active today Mark Andrews also there too
and of course Marquis Brown these were
all injuries that were up in the air
somewhat but they are all good to go so
you're playing England with confidence
Mark Andrews is right inside my top 12
and Marquis Brown is a last kind of
ditch effort guy didn't play a ton of
snaps last week but it's a good matchup
against the Arizona Cardinals two
players we know we will not have though
this week are sterling Shepherd and
Jordan Reed both players dealing with
concussions Shepherd being out remember
we're into week two of golden Tate's
suspension for the Giants we could be
seeing 15-plus targets or ebony on Evan
Engram from a volume standpoint could
end up being the top tight end this week
Jordan Reed being out I will tell you
gives me a bit of a reason maybe cheap
DFS play maybe if you're hurting at the
tight end position to take a look at
Vernon Davis who did come through last
week one Reed was out I know we saw from
Terry Maclaurin and I know we don't have
Darius Geist and Chris Thompson who was
a sleeper last week came through but if
you're really hurting a tight end take a
look at Vernon Davis all right we move
on now to one other big team or maybe
not a big team maybe a sad team and I
have Jets fans as friends then I feel
for them because on Monday night they
will play the Cleveland Browns that
matchup is not easy it got a lot tougher
in the last week with everything that
has happened to the New York Jets this
is this is a great representation of the
New York Jets in the last week and
probably for a lot of Jets fans entire
lives this is what it feels like to be a
Jets fan I am a New York Mets fan I can
understand that but the New York Jets
you had Sam Bradford sue me
Sam Donald I will continue to say that
in jinxing Sam Donald has mono we're not
going to see him Monday we might not see
him for a couple of weeks late on bail
had to get a name around the shoulder
he's going to play but he's not 100%
quincy noon watt he's on the IR they
trade for Demaryius Thomas
he's already banged up there's injuries
on the defense it is not fun to be a
Jets fan it will not be fun to be a Jets
fan on Monday Night Football so they get
their own injury report because that's
how bad things are trevor simians
starting got a downgrade Robbie Anderson
all right so there's injuries
there's the Jets on their own let's
start to get to your questions and we'll
get the plenty of them throughout the
show so let's get going for week number
two with your questions the Shaun Watson
or Lamar Jackson see how do you have
that decision to make I'm gonna play
Lamar Jackson against the vault so it's
gonna be against the Arizona Cardinals
crushed starter bench Devonta Freeman
against Philly and non PPR Cohen is my
backup I like Freeman and I'll continue
to say this throughout the show I really
want to get a piece of that eagles
falcons matchup I think could be a
fantasy frenzy between those two teams
moving on here a very NEMA is cam worth
keeping I am concerned about cam and I
have concerns about cam this is not be
overreacting for the first two weeks in
the season I concerns about cam I'm
wondering if he's damaged goods if you
have him I think you should be looking
around for a second quarterback not
necessarily moving on from Cam Newton
moving on here
hey what's I expect him to show in
Jackson the rest of season I got to show
on a lot of teams I told a lot of people
to go get the challenge accident and
what we saw last week I wasn't surprised
I think DeSean Jackson you want to play
as a wide receiver three who has wide
receiver to potential by the way that
includes today against the Atlanta
Falcons dropped Evan Coleman for Chris
Thompson half point look I don't know
when Coleman's gonna be back it could be
some time you want to make that move I
have no problem cutting to haven't
called it already expecting another big
day from Danny Amendola I don't think
that will be a regular occurrence with
Danny Amendola I thought he was in a
good spot with the Detroit Lions but I
think he's more of a last guy in my
lineup if I get 10 from him in a PPR I
call it a victory now let's go to the
board for a viewer question
Vanessa I see you're still high on air
in jail
so Aaron Jones a lot of people not only
for Vanessa a lot of people ask me about
Aaron Jones wanting to sit him in week 2
where did you draft Aaron Jones third
round fourth round did he get hurt
no he played one football game against
an excellent defense and he was under a
new head coach with a new offense if I
took Aaron Jones in the first four
rounds my draft
I'm not sitting him in week two unless
I'm in a four person league you're
overreacting to one week of football
I know it's Minnesota it's not an easy
matchup and maybe he won't be great
again this week either but we can't
overreact so early in the season to a
player we believed in you can't just
give up on a guy because you took him to
Round four if you got a guy in the 8th
9th 10th round you don't want to plan
this week that's fine but you got to
have faith in Aaron Jones because tough
matchups go both ways and he's darn good
running back all right we move on here
is it time oh yes you might be feeling a
little sleepy right now but you
shouldn't be
[Music]
moving on deep sleepers are coming your
way
[Music]
first deep sleeper of the week is going
to be Josh Allen now last week we had
Matthew Stafford on here Josh Allen
when in doubt hashtag look for legs
scored the rushing touchdown last week
I'm not saying he's gonna have a dak
Prescott day against the Giants but I
like to match up against the Giants I
always want a piece of that matchup
against the Giants and that's another
team you might want to follow around
this year he's got John Brown look at
the passing numbers will be better for
Josh Allen as a whole this season I have
him inside my top 10 let's move on to
now a wide receiver here meet Cole
Hardman is Sammy Watkins a top 10 wide
receiver he absolutely is
as long as Tyreke Hills not out there
but there were questions about Tyreke L
going back to the NFL Draft and his
availability for this season so what are
the Chiefs do they trade it up to go get
meat Cole Hardman because he has a
similar skill set now I'm not telling
you he's gonna start getting 8 9 10
targets but this is the type of player
that if he hits a big player to could
win you a week will outplay his value in
DFS and if you're ever really stuck hey
I always want a piece one of the best
offenses in football and that's where me
Cole Hardman is with the Kansas City
Chiefs let's grab another one here one
more sleeper for this week and in his
word he most hurt now admittedly he's
the lowest of this group I know it's
gonna be Matt burry to show with Tevin
Coleman out but they're gonna use
multiple backs and Rahim most dirt was
brought back by the Niners this season
and oh by the way Raheem most dirt was
proven coming out of last season we
actually saw him step up and give us
some fantasy production the Niners
against the Bengals today not a matchup
I'm particularly worried about from a
defensive end so looking for a last guy
in the lineup or just to have some depth
on your bench I'm not even saying you
have to play them this week but I would
take a look at Raheem ulster you checked
out my article by the way those guys are
in at Vernon Davis Derek Carr last week
we had John Brown and Matthew Stafford
and Darren Waller so if you're looking
for a sleeper yes it's only week to
consider some of those players back to
the questions we go right now as you try
to get ready for week number two we'll
take your lineup questions here cousins
are Mayfield I'm gonna play Baker
against the Jets on Monday Night
Football expect the bounce-back week for
the Browns and I start to uy Hilton
Johnny anytime you're asking the
question who else will be playing but
yes T wise in my top 40 so I'm gonna
guess he's gonna be in your line of
Crisco
our son Austin Eckler Wow I think
Carson's a little safer than Austin
Eckler Eckler is the upside play but
you're in a pretty good spot up here
both of those guys at one of them is
going on the bench moving on here
Lockett woods or D Jack we're gonna
start - I got to play Robert woods
against the Saints I expect a lot of
scoring between the Rams and the Saints
if you want to go with D Jax overlock
and I have no problem with that big game
from John Ross against the Niners I'm
not expecting it I think he was more of
a one-week wonder than what we're gonna
see on the regular from John Ross so I
try to sell high on Alan Robinson based
on not a terrible idea because I'm gonna
guess based on that you're a little bit
worried about Mitch - Biscay so I like
Alan Robinson but you might want to sell
Heine
all right let's go out we are live here
in Las Vegas we are at the sports book
and we got some questions from the crowd
so we're gonna walk out there right now
as you see that's exactly what I'm doing
and let's get a question from our crowd
hi what's your name Kelly Kelly what's
your question do you think Derek Henry
is gonna have another big week I'm a
little worried that Derek Henry is not
going to catch a 75 yard touchdown
because he doesn't do that all the time
and in fact that was like seeing a bald
eagle so I don't see a big week from
Derek Henry I see a solid week from him
good luck thank you there you go Derek
Henry doesn't catch long touchdowns that
often won't go too crazy better but now
it's time for a Matz moment
ah yes
time for a Matz moment here's what I'm
going to tell you to do very simply
let's let's focus here if you have
anyone taking on the Miami Dolphins
start them if you have Bill Belichick in
a fantasy head coach League start him
and that includes today the New England
Patriots head down to Miami we are going
to make sure that you play anyone
against the Miami Dolphins the Patriots
are down there they got the Cowboys
coming up we're playing them we're
playing Michael Gallup we're playing the
Cowboys defense we're playing that
Prescott if they get relegated to the
CFL and the Canadian Football League and
they're playing the Saskatchewan
Roughriders if they go to Regina and
they experience Regina you're gonna have
some fun playing against the Miami
Dolphins simple as that if they go
across the pond and for some reason
they're planning it's Man United start
all the man United guys we want to
follow the Dolphins around all season
long because they're tanking and they're
gonna be the worst team the league and
if you play your players against them
you're going to win follow the Dolphins
things will work out for you that has
been a Matz moment but now we have to
get to more of your questions so very
simply if there's a Patriots question
yes they're playing the Dolphins asleep
but let's get to your questions right
now trade Darren Waller for Sammy
Watkins if someone makes that deal for
you stop watching this show and go ahead
except on that trade because they're
crazy but yes go get Sammy Watkins
continuing here Aaron Jones versus miss
Sona
Minnesota or Duke Johnson versus
Jacksonville I'll say in PPR I'll go
Duke Johnson on on PPR while Aaron Jones
Jones PI a little bit safer Goff for
Allen wow this is a tough one here I'm
gonna go with Jared Goff but I do have
Allen right next to their back and forth
I trust Goff a little bit more Tom Brady
and Lamar Jackson I don't think you can
go wrong with this one Tom Brady though
against the Dolphins as we just said I
can't go against my own advice I'll tell
you to stay put Noah Brady you got to
trade there to make is James White
playing he made the trip to Miami his
wife is expecting and
day now so work close to kickoff it
looks like he will be playing at least
for this week well true Biscay recover -
hunter look I like true Biscay and
fantasy more than reality he did not
play that great last week I'd rather
have them as a backup than a starter we
have a now a celebrity question let's
hear from that one yo what up Matt it's
Matt responsi here host of untold
stories and I've got a question for you
I drafted Alba Kamara
so you know I handcuff latavius Murray
is a smart person should and I'm asking
you against the Rams defense in week two
can i play latavius Murray in the Flex
I'm real thin at that spot right now man
I need some answers please
help the brother out bro hey you go
check out master on untold stories and
I'll help you out master I'll give you a
story right here latavius Murray has
value independent of being a handcuff
and by that I mean he can play in your
lineup any given week even if Alvin
Kamara is out there now we would get a
big bump if tomorrow were to miss time
but we saw the Tavia small rescore
touchdown last weekend oh by the way
they want to run the football I know
they have Drew Brees but they want to
run the football so yes you could play
latavius Murray in any given week in the
Flex including this week let's give you
some updates from the inactives
and now we do have some actual updates
first of all Joe Mixon is in he will
play tonight now he's clearly not a
hundred percent the matchup against the
Niners is okay he is outside my top 20
running backs if you're really stuck and
want to throw Bernard in there you can
do so Mike Williams is also active today
now I don't think he's 100% I think we
could see him in certain packages he
would be outside my top 30 maybe you
were thinking him as a wide receiver - I
still would downgrade him by the way
this could be an extremely busy week for
Keenan Allen he's my number three wide
receiver for the week in PPR and just
reviewing mark and Mark Ingram
Mark Andrews and Marquis Brown are all
in today for the Ravens like them all
against the Arizona Cardinals and as we
know the concussions here for Sterling
Shepherd
Jordan Reed expected ton of targets for
Evan Engram remember Golden Tate is
still on suspension so it could be a
15th target game for Evan Engram and
then Jordan Reed being out if you're
really stuck have Vernon Davis in my
sleepers article throw them in there as
a cheap DFS play so there's your updated
we are up-to-date and those are the big
injuries we talked about the jab
Le'Veon Bell should be out there on
Monday night you won't see Donald
because of mono although according to
Chris Martenson report this morning he
is feeling better so injuries not too
bad for week 2 other than of course what
has happened in the last couple days oh
it's time for the the speed round
and we did some extra training after I
wasn't fast enough I was out in the heat
coach how we feeling today all right
that's just all the confidence I need it
is time for your speed round look I'm
sweating the IFP is popping out but
we're here for you let's go
Big Ben or Josh Allen I like Josh Allen
this week he's inside my top ten and
higher than Ben roll on Yoda
start Sammy Watkins Raby Sammy Watkins
top-10 receiver keep it going as Marlon
Mack and RB one from Indy man Andy man
might be a little bit influenced there
I'd rather Marlon Mac as a high-end RB
to keep it going here con man 98 Josh
Gordon Chris Thompson a mile Sanders I
probably still lean towards Gordon
because of the matchup but I would say
this if there's a big breakout week for
Mile Sanders it's coming today against
the Atlanta Falcons Calvin Ridley or Ted
Ginn wasn't surprised that Ted Ginn went
off but I like Calvin Ridley more as I
said I really want to get a piece of
that eagles falcons match up Chris
Thompson retire Lockett I'll go Thompson
here Thomson's auto-locking year of
Susan I think Thompson's more of a flex
option as we move on Taco Tuesday
Le'Veon status going to play on Monday
MRI was precautionary I'm not worried
about him too much let's go 13 last week
you can find me I'm in better shape than
lady I'll bail in the Jets a Waller or
Fitzgerald I like Fitz this week working
a lot out of the slot they're spreading
it out there throwing it a bunch I'll go
with the volume of Larry Fitzgerald
Peter Center James white white is there
I'm playing James white my problem with
Peterson and watched in general are
there gonna be enough carries there I
don't think there will be I like James
white against the dolphin so I play a B
today to Humble inside my top 20 yes
you're playing him today against the
Miami Dolphins alright let's keep it
going
rockets in or Delanie Walker all right
I'll split the difference Yankee season
I think Walker is safer but if you had a
bad Thursday night game maybe you had
Chris from McCaffrey you want to shoot
for the upside play TJ Hawkinson start
Sony Michelle or Burkett once again I
know
last number came from last week I think
Sony Michelle's getting 20 carries
against the Dolphins because the
Patriots will play with a lead marked
Andrews over DK Metcalf in my Flex game
breathe DB I think game bred yeah I
think in the old Mark Andrews this week
keep it going
Big Bend cousin Stafford or Kyler I
don't love any of these guys but I'll go
Ben against Seattle at home I think
Steelers bounce back I did it we we
eclipsed last week coach all right like
all like all the kids that's what we're
going for well there's a deal if I
didn't get to your question I'm jumping
in the app for the next half hour and
I'll answer as many as I can to get you
ready for week two and beyond you can
catch us here every single Sunday
morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific for
your fantasy prior to fire drill live
here in Las Vegas on that camp good luck
to you and me too this has been your
fantasy fire drill
you
you